my name is Hillary O'Neal and I am a
professional ski Mountaineer and
adventurer and today we are going to
talk about backcountry navigation there
are a lot of uses in many different
environments that would require some
level of skill and backcountry
navigation it's incredibly important to
understand the basics of backcountry
navigation so that you can be
self-sufficient in any adventure you
choose to go on map and compass or
orienteering is almost a sport in and of
itself you start it before you even
leave or pack your bag you can
essentially plot your route out before
you get into the field if for whatever
reason you lose your place on the map
then it's incredibly important to
understand how to read a map to place
yourself on that map when you're in the
backcountry when you're out and you're
using Sun navigation you're basing your
directions off of the time of day and
where the Sun is based on that time of
day a general rule of thumb with Sun
navigation as the width of your hand
equals about an hour you can gauge what
time it is based on how many hand leads
you from your horizon to where the Sun
is in the sky
the simplest most straightforward modern
way of navigating would be using
electronics I use a Gaia GPS app and
that allows you to download maps so that
would fear out in the backcountry and
you're out of service you still have
access to the map the one thing with all
electronical navigation is that they are
battery-powered and so I always have a
compass and a map in my backpack as
backup it's important to practice these
in an environment that you know and are
familiar with and then get outside and
get lost and use navigation to find your
way back home
[Music]